[拍手]
陶芸家の前田コーチです
皆さんは生きがいについて考えたことある
でしょうか私は考えたことがあります
プロジェクトの成功大切な人との食事
感動する映画をその見てる時はいかが
でしょうかそもそも最高に人生を楽しんで
いるその瞬間そういう時はね
幸福だとか生きがいについておそらく考え
もしません考えるのは
なんだかね少し
ぼーっとしてね
人生ってなんか結構大変だなと思ってね
そしてどうすれば良いんだろうかって考え
たその瞬間からではないでしょうかそこで
普段考えない生きづらさこれを乗り越えて
いくための生きがいについて少し考えて
みようと思いました
私の答えは生きがい
そんなものは
存在しません
です
生きがいがねテーマなのに
唐突に何を言うんだと思われたかもしれ
ませんがある意味ね否定しない方が
楽に生きれるとそう思ったからです
それとこういう講演とかね
プレゼン聞いたからと言って多分なんて
言うかなその人生が急に変わることこう
いうことって
滅多にありませんよねですが今日は
必ず皆さんに何かを持ち帰っていただき
少しでも変われるそのように願っており
ますでは生きがい
かっこいいとかねドラマチックとかねそう
いう内容じゃなくてねそれもありかなって
いうそういうことで十分ではないでしょう
か私はそう思います大事なことは誰でも
自分のね世界があるということに気づける
ことですそしてその世界を自らが作って
いけるって感じ始めればどうでしょう
こんなワクワクすることないですよね
そうすれば目の前にあるやるべきこと
このことに目を向けることができて一種の
フロー体験つまり大好きな何かに没頭
するっていうねあの状態あの感覚を
味わえるのではないでしょうか私の場合
自分にとってね
幸福
成功
祝いこういうものは大した問題では
なくなりましたそして考えなくなりました
またその対極にある不安とかねストレス
そういうものは少しずつね
少し減っていったように感じました
そこで私がそういうふうに感じ取れるに
至った経緯についてちょっと今日お話し
たいと思います私は
茶道の道具
桃山時代戦国桃山時代ね20数年だけです
けどね存在した
焼き物の再生というものの
研究と家業である農業これに取り組みます
どちらもねかなりアナログ的な肉体労働
中心なんですけど現在は新たなフェーズと
してここにちょっとね出てますけどね
えーと
伝統工芸にかけるNFTっていう
プロジェクトに参加します
また私の作品がねどのようにして生み出さ
れているのかそういうものを一般の方々に
分かりやすくお伝えするための言葉を獲得
するために国立大学で
研究機関そういうところで
放射光を使った作品の解析今そういうのに
今でちょっとやってるところなんですよね
ちょっと楽しみですけどねそして
農業の方こちらではNパワーというね
微生物そういうものを使った新たな農法に
挑戦しますどちらも私の活動が
社会といかに連動してそして
持続可能性というものを実現できるかの
チャレンジです今ねずっとねめちゃくちゃ
かっこいいこと言ってきましたよね現実は
過酷な労働のオンパレードです例えば年度
当時使われてた粘土も
掘り起こされて多分ね掘り尽くされてない
んですよなので年度全部自分でブレンドし
て作ることになります場合によったら長い
年月かかりますつまりねすぐに使える粘土
ではないんですよまた一度焼くのにね家数
件分建てれる
材木これね自らの手で割って巻き作るん
ですよ
また
やきものお焼くときのねカマだけなんです
けど4日から5日間
ずっと寝ずに焼き続けるんですよ
ねでこれらのことはねそのなんて言うかな
その
かなりねあの大変な作業でね
研究で私さっきもやっていますって言い
ましたけど実はその研究内容っていうのが
ねその焼き方これ結構重要でして
燃焼
温度これが世界で一番
温度が高いんですよ1400度っていう
温度に上げるんですよねこれ言葉で言う
のってほんと簡単なんですけど実は非常に
難しいことなんですよね
でそれって
例えばねなんでそんなことが必要かという
と実はそのね
研究している作品そういうの魅力が
炎と土による
有機的なその化学反応に起こって起こる
傭兵と呼ばれる景色になるからなんですよ
茶道の世界ではねそれらの見栄をこれをね
景色と呼んで愛でるっていうそういう粋な
ことをするんですね
それで私にはそのような人生に導いてくれ
た先生と呼べる人がいました
出会いこれって人生においてねいかに
かけがえのないねその意味と天気になるの
かっていうの私は知ることになったんです
当時先生は大学の学部長でしたでもね私は
実はね経営学部の学生だったんですよね
ですから自分がその子の
伝統工芸とか芸術こういうものに携わると
は全く思ってませんでしたですから
陶芸にも全く興味なかったんですねしかし
先生のその生活態度これにすごく
カルチャーショック受けましたそして私は
そのうちこういう人生をも自分も歩めるん
であろうかって思うようになったんです
ですから一緒に研究しようって声をかけ
られた時その時にどうして自分がって思っ
たんですけどねその反面ねなんか自分
かっこいい人間になれるんじゃないだろう
かっていうそういう実は不純な時で始めた
んですよね先生は人間国宝と研究もされて
たという経歴もあって数々の登り窯を自ら
製作してそして
独自の理論をね開発したってそういう方
でした彼のことを知ってる人はよくこう
言います超人そのような人物ですから
エピソードには事欠きません例えば
薪を入れるこういう動きなんですけどこれ
と体力を身につけるのに当時バドミントン
部の顧問を始めたわけですから自らが全国
チャンピオンになるというそういう方だっ
たんですね
すごいんですよつまりね
探究心と実践の熱量これが半端ありません
でした
でもねこういう一面もあったんですよある
時突然家にね招待されたんですよそして
豪華な料理をご馳走になりましたフグの
酵素類とお酒に食べてなさいちょっと用事
があるからって言われたんで食べてたん
ですけどね
毒あるんですよ
猛毒で先生こう来てたからちょっとね
驚いてね先生すごいですね
免許調理免許まで持ってるんですねいや
持ってないよって言ったんですよ
ねその後よし食べれるなって私で実験です
よまあそんなね
大丈夫やったんですけど私でもねそんな
先生にすごく生活態度に惹かれていったん
ですよね
家具もねほとんど手作りでした
洗練されてたというよりは何て言うかな
人間味があってそして
統一感があっていや本当に美しいと思った
んですよその先生の口癖これがね私だから
これができるって言うんだろうと思ってる
だろ違う誰でもできるそうなんですよ
ほとんどの方がねできないって思い込ん
でるだけでね世の中の大抵のことはできる
というそういうことなんですよつまり
考え方がいかに大切かということです
人生で乗り越えるべき大きな課題があると
いうことは本当に嬉しいことです
課題ような人生これはね虚しくて味気ない
ものなんですよね
初めて発注した
原木が実家に届いた時のこと今でも昨日の
によく覚えてます
そのね先生が来れるまでにちょっと準備し
とけと言われたんでまたそれを持とうと
思った時に感触これも出るのこれ割れるの
ほんまにこれ割れるのって思ったんですよ
あのね皆さんこんなんです直径人間の
トータルはるかに大きいもので長さ直径
60cm長さ4mに切られた原木です
もちろん全く持ち上がりませんまずこれ
チェーンソーで切るの本当に大変なんです
よましてや斧で割る言うまでもありません
全く歯が立たない何度振り下ろしても全く
割れないただ鈍い音だけが響く当たるだけ
です今考えたらね闇雲に
浮上してるだけです機能名を本当は見るん
ですけどそんなものを知らないただ身体が
困憊していくだけ私先生に何度も電話かけ
ました先生発注ミスです
何度も言いましたでも先生はただそれで
良いから終わり続けなさいって言われたん
ですよ
ね私心の中ではないと思いながらねそれで
も終わり続けたんですよそして先生が来
られるその当日来られました先生そのね
原木を見てもね
涼しげなこれじゃあ割っていこうかって
言ったんですよそして一振りされました
驚きましたその一撃その気からしんちゃん
にで響いてくるんですよ
音が違うんですその時先生と初めて会って
ね受けた衝撃また
そうこれだってあのね本当に不思議なん
ですけどね割れてないのに自分の力強さに
気づくんですよ割れてたらわかるんですよ
割れてないのになんですよつまり何かに
向かって出し切る自分はただこのね作業を
続けるんだって
覚悟した
その時に私自分の本当の力がどれぐらい
あるんか言われてないんですけど気づいた
んですよこれがね不思議にね嬉しかったん
ですよで先生と一緒にね1ヶ月待ってたら
ね割れるっていう感覚がわかるようになっ
てきましたそして大木が割れ出したんです
よ
脳は分かってなくてもねこの
身体は何かに気づき始めてそしてねその頃
にはもう知っているんですよ皆さんね人間
って本当に素晴らしいですよ思われないと
思ったのに自分はこの身体をかけて続ける
んだって覚悟を決めたその瞬間からね
気づきが始まるんですよそれはね1ヶ月か
もしれないです1年後かもしれないもしか
したらね10年後かもしれません
でもいいですか皆さん本当に死ぬことに
なるんです
よ
自分のことです自分を知るということをね
ある意味世界を知るということと同じです
私にはもう一つ大きな課題がありました
1400度皆さん1400度って想像でき
ます
焚き火あれがね250度から450あれ
すごい1500と例えばカマだけ2日目
手前の大きな卓上から大きさ30cm
マルタリティも5秒かかります両
サイドから割った薪を入れてもマッチ棒の
ように瞬間に模様が入ってきますもうね
温度が高すぎてイエス剣の最終燃えても
ハイになってもねバケツにあるかないか
ですもうこの領域になったらねただ真木を
区別続けたからといって出せるような温度
ではないです
緻密なで繊細なねハードでそういう理論と
テクニックが必要になってくる
でもこれがどのようなものかというのは
言語化するのかね非常に難しい世界です
入れたと言ってもね
温度絶対分かりませんまあせいぜい
1200度ですしかし先生が出続けるとね
安定したいやほんと不思議です
先生いつもねにっこりね不思議だろって
笑ってました私も先生の言う通りに入れて
いくと
温度上げたんですよねそれが本当に何を
示すか当時の私分かったつもりにいたん
ですよつもりやったんですよ
そして6年後先生は亡くなり私の前からい
なくなりました当時はほとんど研究って形
を取ってるので誰も訪ねてきませんつまり
誰からも称賛されません周りの人はただね
体壊して
多分
借金だけが残るのはやめなさいと言われた
んです
よではその当時私生きがいはなかったの
でしょう
かいやそうではありません
ただ目の前にあるべきことこれが自分の
世界だと覚悟を決めてないいつやってくる
かわからない良いことや悪いことそういう
のに向けるのではなくそういう世界が自分
の本当に世界だと覚悟を決めた瞬間にね
些細なことには気が通らなくなって今ある
この自自身の状態これがあるべき自然な
本来の状態だって感じるようになってきた
んですよ私は自然相手に作業してきたんで
自然はどうにもならない
存在だって
そういう風に身体がね反応していくことに
よってね
自然とねそういう状態を受け入れるように
なれた
んです日本語において自然とはね本来
自ずということらしいですそれになぞらえ
ていればおのずとそうなっていくっていう
感じでしょうかそれは今現在自分は
はっきり生きていれるっていうそういう
状態言い切れる状態だったんです
そのような状態そのような世界ではね
わざわざ生きがいなんていうことはね
考えることはなさそうですというのが私の
主将なんですよ大切なのはいかに寄り添っ
てありようを受け入れるか例えば人間
川を作りますよね水をコントロールしよう
としますよねでもトーンも見つかられたら
自分が一番進みやすいこの進路このことを
私たちが
川と名付けてるだけですよね例えば炎に
とってみれば本来自分がどうありたいか
そうありようねどう達成していけるのかと
いうのを考えたら見え方が変わったんです
よねそして
炎なりを受け入れた途端に実は自分に対し
ても変わったんですよ
コントロールしてやろうとかねあ自分の
ものにするそういう考え方を自分は今まで
していたんだということを知ることになり
ましたそして炎ありを受けるようにしまし
たそうするとね炎の邪魔をしない今入れる
べき
薪をね入れるべきタイミングじゃないって
いうのがわかるようになってきたんですよ
まあかっこよく言えば
炎の呼吸そういうものを見ながらで薪を
入れたら不思議ですが自然にゆっくり温度
上がってくるようになったんですよね
そして全く不安が全くと言えば言い過ぎ
ですけど不安はなくなりました例えば天候
が悪くなって温度が下がってきますよね
これは問題ではなくなりました次から次へ
と私の前にやるべき
課題っていうのがね
姿を現すのが
わかるようになってきた
んですよそうなんですよ自然に逆らうので
はなくね自らのありをこれも受け入れる
覚悟を決めたらその瞬間からね気づいた時
にはねどうすればいいかっていうのが
わかるようになってた
んですよ自らのありを受け入れるその時
私たち
初めて私たちは自らの自分の世界というの
をね構築できるそういう土俵に立てるんで
はないでしょうか
私たち一人ひとりのありを私たち一人一人
がねちょっとアーティストなんですよその
心に持ったね思いとか行動こういうものが
ね例えば
彫刻家で例えるならねその手に持ったノミ
の一刀一等となってね私たちが世界という
作品をね掘り上げていくんではない
でしょうか
今ある自分のこのねありをこれを
受け入れる
過去とか未来とかじゃないですよ今の
アリオを受け入れるって言うそういうこと
が大事なんです
よね人生にはねちょっとした覚悟があり
ますその覚悟とは
例えば人生には良いことさっきも良いこと
悪いことがあるようになりますがそんな
ことは実はないんじゃないかなと私は思う
んですよね全てはただ目の前から次々やっ
てくる事実があるのみでそのように見える
のはねおそらく
概念的な言葉の使い方だけだと私は思い
ますそう考えるつまりそういうものが生き
るっていうことだって覚悟を決めるとね
出来事のすべてが
必要不可欠な部分だと
そう思えるようになってきたんです
よね実際私も面白いことにそうなってき
ました
先ほども言いましたけどね自分のありを
これをね
素直に受け入れる
過去とか未来とかじゃないですよ今の
アリオ
これが大切だということです皆さんにお
伝えしたいことが真に価値を持つのはそう
いったことを実際に取り入れてみてもらっ
て皆さんの人生で
生きがいこれが皆さんのアリをそのものだ
と感じられる時です
それには
あなた自身のありを今を
[拍手]